From now on, we won't start the strategy meeting for the first ruined end hall day Please
do something good for
Katarina Kuroiso dears I don't have to get engaged to you But
I've already done it from Sea World  And I
wonder if I can do that Yeah, I'm sure I
still have to go when it's time.It
's the duty of those who have magical powers to go to a magic school.
It was the first time I moved my enemy to my alma mater, right?
To think that I had to enroll in a school for such magical powers?
There are times when
it's time to put it away, so the Earth Old puts on the mask of an angel and quickly
rose.If it's to be tied to the main character, there's even the possibility of demeaning Katarina.
For when
that
happens, it's better to increase your magical powers.
Are you sure you want to improve your polishing ability?
What the heck are you doing, young lady?
Speaking of interacting with the soil and interacting with the soil in order to increase your magical power, who
is the one who talks to Tsuji when you're growing a field?
uc Uoi doesn't make sense at all, and I feel
like I'm fundamentally wrong on some days.